[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition en direct du Sénat
votre programme qui revient tous les
jeudis après-midi sur les temps fort de
l'actualité de la chambre haute du
parlement voici le sommaire de cette
émission premier titre cette semaine et
le Sénat qui adopte définitivement le
projet de loi immigration s'ouvre
désormais un bras faire entre sénateur
et députés mais également au sein des
républicains deuxème titre dans cette
émission et le Sénat qui s'empare du
projet loit de financement de la
sécurité sociale depuis lundi
effectivement cela signe le début du
marathon budgétaire ici au Sénat un
budget marqué par les déficits et qui
inquiète les sénateurs de la majorité
sénatoriale ensuite nous écouterons les
dirigeants de l'Agence France Presse ils
étaient reçus mardi au Sénat sur fond de
polémique la FP qui n'utilise pas le
terme terroriste pour qualifier le Hamas
ou alors avec des guillemets vous
entendrez les explications des
dirigeants de la FP et enfin nous
évoquerons les agressions envers les
enseignants le Sénat qui a lancé une
commission d'enquête 3 ans après la mort
de Samuel paatti cette semaine c'est le
Ministre de la Fonction publique
Stanislas Guerini qui était
reçu mais d'abord les suites de
l'adoption du projet de loi immigration
le vote solennel du texte a eu lieu
mardi en séance après une semaine de
débat sur le fond du texte écouez les
extraits des explications de vote
c'était mardi en séance cela préparé par
mathil notarelli et Ella cou après une
semaine de débat en séance nous sommes
appelés à nous prononcer sur un texte
qui est le fruit d'abord de la volonté
politique du gouvernement et ensuite
d'un compromis qui doit nous permettre
d'avancer au-delà des postures
l'essentiel est bien là réussir à
relever les défis posés pour notre pays
comme pour tous les pays européens par
une meilleure maîtrise des flux
migratoires par l'absolue nécessité de
mieux protéger nos compatriotes des
délinquants étrangers et de réussir
l'intégration de ceux qui ont vocation à
rester sur le territoire
national la volonté politique du
gouvernement est claire adapter notre
droit aux nouvelles réalités migratoires
que connaissent tous les pays avec
lesquels nous pouvons être
raisonnablement comparés en corrigeant
une trajectoire qui n'est pas soutenable
dans la durée pour notre cohésion
nationale nous nous réjouissons d'abord
de la bonne qualité dans l'ensemble et
sur un sujet aussi passionné des débats
qui se sont déroulés au sein de notre
hémicycle j'exprime nos remerciements
d'abord à monsieur le ministre de
l'Intérieur pour son sens de l'écoute du
dialogue et du compromis à nos deux
rapporteurs pour le sérieux de leur
travail et au président buffet sans qui
j'en suis certain nous ne son pas nous
ne serions pas arrivés à ce point
d'équilibre je crois que nous pouvons
collectivement nous satisfaire de la
méthode adoptée discussion en premier
lieu d'un texte important au Sénat c'est
évidemment un message de confiance en
direction de notre assemblée qui nous a
été envoyée enrichissement du projet
gouvernemental par les travaux en
commission et reprise par le
gouvernement de la quasi-ttalité des
propositions ainsite faites enfin un
travail en séence qui aura permis de
faire encore évoluer le texte par contre
et je le dis très clairement certaines
de ces évolutions nous ont profondément
heurté une en particulier la suppression
de l'aide médicale
d'État nous espérons que l'Assemblée
nationale revient sur ce qui représente
à nos yeux une faute morale et une
erreur grave en matière de santé
publique le dispositif de l'Ame
correspond à une exigence élémentaire
d'humanité notre pays doit rester fidèle
à sa tradition et ses valeurs humanistes
l'idée de conditionner l'accès au soins
d'un individu par hypothèse en
souffrance à la régularité de sa
situation administrative est pour nous
tout simplement
insupportable aussi nous comprenons et
soutenons la démarche des milliers de
soignants qui refusent d'être placés
dans une impasse déontologique du fait
de la loi aucun argument sérieux ne
vient raisonnablement à l'appui d'une
suppression de la me l'affirmation selon
laquelle la me exercerait un appel d'air
ne repose sur aucun élément chacun le
sait aucune économie ne serait réalisée
en cas de suppression bien au contraire
les pathologies seraient prises en
charge plus tardivement ce qui peut être
dramatique pour les personnes concernées
et encore plus coûteux pour la
collectivité cette mesure si elle était
définitivement adoptée viendrait de plus
opérer un transfert de charg entre
l'État l'État et l'hôpital public et
engorgerait encore davantage nos
services d'urgence non franchement le
jeu politique a aussi ses limites et il
n'est pas possible de jouer ainsi avec
la santé et donc la vie d'être humain si
laame doit être réformée elle l'a
d'ailleurs déjà été réformons-la et nous
étudierons d'ailleurs avec attention le
rapport demandé par le gouvernement à
Monsieur à Messieurs stéphanini et Evin
mais de grâce ne jetons pas le bébé avec
l'eau du bain nous regressons aussi la
suppression de l'article 4 qui prévoyait
un accè un accès accéléré au marché du
travail pour les demandeurs d'asile dont
le besoin de protection est manifeste
quelle curieuse idée pour la majorité
sénatoriale de préférer ainsi
l'assistana supporté financièrement par
le contribuable à la possibilité ouverte
pour les personnes concernées de
travailler et donc de s'intégrer plus
rapidement ce renoncement à la valeur
travail est difficilement compréhensible
surtout à un moment où nos entreprises
sont en pénurie de main d'œuvre nous
déplorons enfin que les facilité d'accès
à un titre de séjour pour les médecins
diplômés à l'étranger ayant déjà reçu
l'autorisation d'exercer en France et
été rejeté au moment où tant de
territoires souffrent d'un manque de
praticiens cette décision est
regrettable d'autant plus qu'il était
question même pas de 400 situation par
an par contre nous nous réjouissons du
maintien d'un dispositif de
régularisation pour les salariés dans
les métiers en tension la majorité
sénatoriale a préféré s'en remettre
largement au pouvoir discrétionnaire des
préfets et donc Infiné du ministre de
l'intérieur plutôt qu'à des critères
impératifs pour l'administration fixé
par le le législateur lui-même quitte
d'ailleurs à durcir ce proposé par le
gouvernement pour notre part nous ne
saons pas dans la posture article 3 ou 4
bis la belle affaire l'essentiel est
bien que le dispositif de régularisation
existe dans les métiers en tension pour
les étrangers exprimant la volonté de
s'intégrer ce dispositif viendra
faciliter l'intégration des étrangers
concernés mais viendra aussi satisfaire
un besoin pour nos entreprises les
dispositions concernant les étrangers
délinquants ou constituant une menace
grave pour l'ordre publique ont
également été maintenu c'était pour nous
un dispositif central du texte car
destiné à mieux protéger nos
concitoyens nous nous félicitons du
rétablissement des articles 2 5 et 8 qui
avaient été supprimés par notre
commission comme nous nous réjouissions
de tous les dispositifs spécifiques au
territoires ultramarins qui ont pu être
adoptés souvent grâce au sénateurs du
groupe RDPI autre motif de satisfaction
l'adoption de notre abonnement
durcissant les sanctions applicables aux
reconnaissances frauduleuse de paternité
oui le groupe RDPI votera
majoritairement pour ce texte en sachant
que l'Assemblée nationale reviendra sur
certaines dispositions que nous rejetons
d'autres dispositions sont manifestement
des cavaliers législatifs car portant
sur la nationalité et seront sanctionné
sans aucun doute par ailleurs il ne
s'agit donc en aucun cas pour nous de
donner quitus à la majorité sénatoriale
mais simplement d'exprimer notre volonté
d'avancer ensemble au Sénat ne pas
adopter ce projet de loi reviendrait
Infiné à se satisfaire de l'état du
droit actuel ce serait prendre une
lourde responsabilité car notre pays a
besoin de renforcer les exigences conc
l'intégration la protection des Français
la simplification des procédures et la
défense des valeurs de la République je
vous
remercie la parole est à notre collègue
marie-ierre de la Gonterie pour le
groupe
socialiste écologiste et
[Applaudissements]
républicain avez la
parole
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre madame monsieur le rapporteur
monsieur le président de la commission
des lois mes chers collègues nous voilà
donc après ces mois de parcours
chaotique de ce projet de loi présenté
il y a plus d'un an au Conseil des
ministres 8 mois après la commission des
lois cette 20 29e loi sur l'immigration
qui promettait de contrôler
l'immigration et améliorer
l'intégration ce que le ministre de
l'Intérieur résumait par la formule être
gentil avec les gentils et méchant avec
les méchants pourtant un an après
l'intégration a totalement disparu du
texte à l'instar du ministre du Travail
qui n'est toujours pas là aujourd'hui
qui a déserté les débats résultat il ne
s'agit plus que d'être méchant avec les
gentils et avec tous les autres pour
nous la
solidarité la dignité humaine
l'accès au droits fondamentaux ne sont
pas négociables ils sont consubstantiels
à l'ordre public et social à gauche nous
savons ce qu'apportent les étrangers les
travailleurs comme les étudiants à la
société française nous croyons à
l'intégration par le travail par l'accès
à notre langue par l'insertion dans
notre vie associative et sociale mais
avec ce texte l'étranger n'est vu que
comme une menace un froudeur quelqu'un
dont on peut au mieux tolérer la prés
sur notre sol alors qu'aujourd'hui notre
pays fait face à un triple
dysfonctionnement de l'accueil de la
protection de la reconduction nous
réfutons vigoureusement ce discours
simpliste distinguant les bons et les
mauvais étrangers ainsi que le
présupposé selon lequel l'immigration
économique serait plus légitime plus
noble que l'immigration familiale ou
l'asile oui nous considérons que la
régularisation par le travail est
bénéfique à l'ensemble des travailleurs
là où le travail illégal cultive la
précarité et la concurrence est loyale
les travailleurs sans papierers étant
contraint d'accepter d'indiges condition
de travail et de rémunération la non
régularisation des travailleurs sans
papierers laisse prospérer une forme
d'esclavage moderne visiblement au
regard du texte sur lequel nous devons
aujourd'hui nous exprimer ce n'est pas
la position de la majorité sénatoriale
nous sénatrices et sénateurs socialiste
nous opposons fermement à ce que vous
avez introduit la droite et son allié
centriste dans ce projet de loi avec
l'assentiment et la bienveillance du
ministre de l'intérieur nous combattons
la précarisation des étrangers que vous
voulez instaurer par la suppression de
toute allocation non contributive avant
5 années de résidence en situation
régulière punissant ainsi y compris les
enfants par votre refus de régulariser
les étrangers sans papiers dans les
métiers en tenstion mesure pourtant
soutenu par l'ensemble des employeurs et
par les Français par l'exclusion des
étrangers en situation irrégulière du
dispositif d'hébergement d'
les condamnant donc à la rue et par
votre refus d'octroyer aux demandeurs
d'asile le droit au travail d l' dépôt
de leur demande les les condamnant ainsi
à ce que vous dénoncez parfois comme de
guillemets
laassistana nous ne pouvons accepter le
dénis du droit à la santé des étrangers
que vous avez opéré par la suppression
de l'aide médicale d'État qui pourtant
bénéficie à l'ensemble de la population
avec une position gouvernementale que
nous n'arrivons plus à suivre pour un
jour pour selon les minist ministre le
ministre de la Santé contre à titre
personnel pour le ministre de
l'Intérieur pour finalement le soir à la
télé pour finalement la première
ministre et contre finalement au
Parlement et par l'arrêt de la prise en
charge médicale des députés du droit
d'asile nous condamnons résolument vos
atteintes au droits de la nationalité
par l'élargissement que vous avez voté
de la possibilité de déchoir une
personne de C nationalité par la
restriction du droit du sol nous
contestons également les atteintes au
droit à une vie familiale que vous avez
introduit en durcissant considérablement
l'accès au regroupement familial nous
fustigeons avec force les multiples
atteintes aux libertés au respect des
droits auquels vous avez procédé
notamment en passant à 3 années la durée
possible d'une assignation à résidence
enfin nous critiquons les restrictions à
l'accueil des étudiants étrangers et à
l'aide au développement ou à la
politique des visas que vous avez
souhaité Adou
nous faisant ainsi courir le risque
d'une dégradation du rayonnement de la
France politique que l'ambassadeur de
France au Maroc qualifiait hier encore
de gâi ce faisant votre texte mesdames
et messieurs de la majorité sénatoriale
reprend consciencieusement en s'alignant
avec les propositions du Front National
et de Marine Le Pen sur chacun des
thèmes évoqués lors de l'examen de ce
projet de loi votreelle la plus du a
emporté le groupe LR avec le soutien du
groupe centriste sur un texte pourtant
peu conforme à ses idéaux et avec la
compllaisance inquiétante du
gouvernement mais également du groupe
des sénateurs
macronistes cette dérive se poursuit
comme le désirait le Front national avec
la proposition de loi constitutionnelle
de monsieur retaillot qui viendra en
séance le 12 décembre et qui préconise
rien de moins que de se soustraire au
droits de l'union de fixer des quotas
d'étrangers par nationalité et
d'expulser tout étranger condamné une
peine de prison nous vivons aujourd'hui
mes chers collègues un moment de
clarification de la droite française ce
texte au parcours chaotique s'achève
dans un naufrage pour la droite et une
rupture avec notre modèle républicain
mais aussi avec l'héritage du gaulisme
et l'ambition de cohésion que défendait
Jacques Chirac l'un d'entre vous
écrivait il y a 18 mois messieurs du
groupe LR et mesdames du groupe LR chez
les républicains notre faiblesse a été
d'abandonner le terrain au rassemblement
national toute recherche de synthèse
avec l'autre droite que nous combattons
depuis toujours serait contre nature et
nécessairement voué à
l'échec si nous renoncions à la fermeté
de nos convictions nous ne serions plus
rien nous incarnons un idéal qui seerait
être intexé aux aléas de la vie
politique sinon nous ne serions plus que
de simples opportunistes mesdames Mames
et messieurs du groupe LR je viens de
lire les propos de Philippe B nous le
disons aujourd'hui solennellement à la
majorité sénatoriale ne vous laissez pas
dériver vers une droite extrême qui ne
se satisfera jamais de vos propositions
nous le disons au groupe centriste ne
vous laissez pas emporter par cette
dérive orthogonale à cette conception de
la société ne passez pas du compromis à
la compromission il est encore temps de
mettre un terme à cette dérive pour
notre part groupe socialiste nous
prenons nos responsabilités en nous
opposant avec force à une vision de la
France étroite et menacée par chaque
étranger vision qui n'est pas la
nôtre
bon la parole est maintenant au
président François Noël buffet pour le
complet
[Applaudissements]
républicain chers
collègues monsieur le présidentés vous
avez la parole merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Ministre Mesdames et Messieurs les
rapporteurs ce n'est pas comme président
de la commission des lois que je
m'exprime mais au nom du groupe les
républicains je voudrais vous dire au
moment où nous abordons le vote officiel
de ce texte qu'il faut laisser de côté
soit les injures soit les caricatures et
qu'il faut tout de même regarder ce
qu'est la
[Applaudissements]
réalité il n'y a il n'y a je crois comme
base de travail que celle-ci qui vaille
le reste peut-être une une idée une
vision une conception mais elle sent
toujours sur la réalité des faits or
l'ensemble des analyses qui ont été
faite par le Sénat depuis longtemps sur
ce domaine est largement documenté et
d'ailleurs sur le fond jamais
contesté le contexte vous le connaissez
c'est une pression migratoire sans
précédent
régulière de 316000 premier titre en
2022 comme irrégulière 400000
bénéficiaaires de la M estimé par le
ministre lu à plus de 900000 personnes
sur le territoire national et une
incapacité très grande de pouvoir pour
pardon pour le pouvoir public de réagir
à cette intensification de flux la
conséquence et regardons en face les
Français d'ailleurs le considèrent ainsi
un processus d'intégration qui est
grippé pour ne pas dire qui ne
fonctionne pas ce don nous devons nous
désoler des taux d'éloignement qui ne
sont pas bons chacun le sait tous les
chiffres sont connus les TF c'est de
l'ordre de 7 % c'est évidemment
largement insuffisant on a eu l'occasion
de s'exprimer sur les raisons et une
chaîne de l'asile au bord de l'implosion
16000 demandes projetées en 2024 un
délai moyen de 11 mois pour traiter les
demandes des dossiers alors que nous
espérions à l'origine 6
mois quelles sont les causes de cette
situation nous pensons pour la majorité
sénatoriale et pour le groupe que je
représente ici c'est d'abord une absence
de vision en terme de politique
migratoire tant que la France n'aura pas
déterminé la politique migratoire
qu'elle souhaite il n'y aura que des
échecs et nous avons souhaité fixer
cette politique migratoire dans le texte
clairement de manière à ce que les
choses soient parfaitement clair pour
tout le monde j'allais dire et que les
mesures qui on découle soit parfaitement
cohérente voilà pour les extraits de la
séance qui se tenait mardi et donc le
Sénat qui a adopter définitivement le
projet de loi immigration pour en parler
j'accueille ici loï carv bonjour bonjour
sénateur centriste de Haute Savoie un
mot sur ce texte maintenant adopté par
le Sénat qui part à l'assemblée
nationale on voit et bien des
difficultés entre sénateurs et députés
les députés notamment de renaissance
l'elle gauche qui veulent réécrire
l'article 3 qui était la clé de voûte de
l'accord entre centristes et LR une
réaction ben je crois que la rédaction
trouvée par le Sénat est une rédaction
d'équilibre qui a permis un accord dans
la majorité sénatoriale mais au-delà
d'AV de proposer un dispositif qui soit
applicable sur le terrain qui réponde
aux besoins des entreprises du monde
économique et
qui finalement soit assez équilibré
entre ce que voulait le gouvernement et
ce que nous voulons nous aussi au Sénat
donc c'est une base de travail j'imagine
pour les
députés entendre parler tout de suite
d'une réécriture ça va ils vont un peu
vite en besogne et ils oublient
peut-être que après la lecture à
l'Assemblée nationale il y aura une
commission mixte paritaire et j'imagine
l'objectif d'un accord parce que nous
quand nous avons eu de cette rédaction
ici au Sénat nous avons l'objectif d'un
accord en commission mixte paritaire et
c'est-à-dire d'un texte qui réponde à ce
que veulent les Français et aux
nécessités du monde économique on
explique la commission mix paritaire qui
réunit se députés se Sénateurs lorsque
deux versions d'un même projet de loi
sont écrites de façon différente au
Sénat et l'Assemblée nationale et quiess
de se mettre d'accord à H clos vous
pensez que cet accord est possible mais
sur quelle base celle du Sénat vous
pensez ah mais je souhaite que cet
accord soit possible sur la base
forcément des deux versions qui seront
celles du Sénat et cell de l'Assemblée
nationale mais il faut ces versions soi
compatiblees parce que si vous d'emblé
vous vous allez sur une une une une
différence trop lourde entre le Sénat et
l'Assemblée nationale vous compromettez
l'accord en CMP et vous aurez sans doute
la nécessité ou de faire capoter le
texte ou d'un ou d'un recours au 49
alinée à 3 donc nous nous voulons ici au
Sénat que les députés s'inspirent de ce
que nous avons fait c'est une
proposition que nous mettons sur la
table mais que de grâce il n'aille pas
trop loin dans la réécriture ou dans la
suppression du 4 bis au profit d'un
nouvel article 3 autre difficulté au
sein même de la famille les républicains
le texte ne fait pas consensus on a
entendu Olivier marlex chef de fil des
députés àir dire qu'il allait durcir le
texte en en séance qu'est-ce que là
encore ça vous évoque en fait ce texte
il plaît à personne convient l'équilibre
convient à personne à l'Assemblée
nationale en tout cas moi je suis
solidaire de l'équilibre que nous avons
trouvé au Sénat c'est un c'est un texte
qui à la fois renforce la lutte contre
les les filières d'immigration
clandestine qui donne un certain nombre
d'outils nouveaux les français nous
attendent sur ce sujet d'immigration
clandestine et en même temps c'est un
texte en même temps vous voyez c'est un
texte qui permet de répondre aux
nécessités de l'économie je viens d'un
département là haut de Savoie qui est un
département dans lequel un certain
nombre de domaines d'activité
l'hôtellerie restauration le bâtiment le
médicosocial
emploie beaucoup de de travailleurs
étrangers et peine à recruter et peine à
recruter donc il il y a il y a vraiment
une une un principe de réalité en fait
par rapport à à l'économie française et
et je trouve qu'au Sénat on a trouvé cet
équilibre là en tout cas moi je suis
totalement solidaire de ce que nous
avons voté l'un des points les plus
polémiques c'est la transformation de
l'aide médicale d'État en aide médicale
d'urgence un panier de soins restreint
pour les S papiers car selon les alr
cela constitué un appel d'air pour les
migrants là encore qu'est-ce que vous
pensez de la polémique les députés qui
ne veulent pas de cette transformation
qui veulent rétablir l'ame le
gouvernement également est-ce que vous
pourriez céder sur ce point écoutez
c'est une polémique totalement stupide
parce que en France on ne laisse mourir
personne en France on soigne quiconque
sur le territoire national quel chis St
mais bien évidemment c'est pour ça qu'on
nous avons transformé l'ame en Amu je
suis quelqu'un qui est extrêmement
sensible aux questions aux questions
sociales mais encore une fois il fallait
peut-être relever un certain nombre de
de risqu ou de fraude ou d'excès et et
encore une fois veiller nous ici au
Sénat on veille à ce que chaque centimes
d'argent public soit aille au bon
endroit qu' s'agisse des impôts des
Français ou qu'il s'agisse des cations
sociales pas de drame la rédaction
sénatoriale de Lau qui est plutôt un
dispositif à la fois opérationnel et et
aussi un dispositif équitable le
sénateur Renaissance Olivier Bitz parle
d'une faute morale et une erreur grave
en matière de santé publique est-ce que
c'est une ligne rouge est-ce que vous
pourrez revenir sur cette décision non
mais dès qu'on introduit de la morale
dans dans dans la politique et je le dis
parfois alors que c'est quelque chose
que je que je m' auquel je m'astreins à
titre personnel mais c'est faire déb
déraper déraper le débat à
volontairement et surtout disqualifier
toute possibilité de discussion donc la
la base de la discussion c'est laemu
votée par le Sénat évidemment comme ça
allit sur l'ensemble de ce texte là il y
aura un débat avec les députés je dis
simplement aux députés notamment de la
majorité de l' gauche de la majorité que
s'ils font déraper le texte c'est
eux-mêmes qui comprettront le les toutes
les chances d'avoir un accord en
commission mixte paritaire accord en
commission mixte paritaire que au Sénat
nous souhaitons
une dernière question un peu politique
qui est-ce qui est le grand gagnant de
l'examen de ce projet de loi est-ce que
c'est Gérald Darmanin on disait avant
l'accord entre centriste et et Alair que
son texte peut-être ne serait pas adopté
du tout finalement il y a une version
qui sort est-ce qu'il est gagnantti
comme à l'accoutumé Gérald armanin a
montré son sérieux il a répondu à
l'ensemble des collègues il se trouve
que j'ai présidé la séance et j'ai vu
comment il répondait et le respect avec
lequel il a traité l'ensemble des
parlementaires quelle que soit leur
sensibilité donc
oui assurément puisque le il sort du
Sénat avec une mouture qui n'était pas
la sienne mais qui est une mouture qui
existe il a il y a un texte qui sort du
Sénat et qui est un texte qui a été voté
assez largement par les sénateurs les
sénatrices donc oui je pense que char
Darmanin a a a réussi son son ce passage
du du du texte au Sénat et bien merci
merci lev on suivra la suite du
feuilleton avec l'examen de ce projet
l'émigration maintenant à l'Assemblée
nationale en décembre merci
merci deuxème thème dans cette émission
et le Sénat qui a entamé le marathon
budgétaire comme chaque automne c'est
tout d'abord le projet de lois de
financement de la sécurité sociale qui
est examiné en séance un projet de lo
financement la sécurité sociale marqué
par d'importants déficits qui
inquièteent les sénateurs regardez ces
extraits de séance préparé par Mathilde
notarelli et Ella C on en parle juste
après avec la rapporteur générale du
budget un
fiscal est encore peu et mal utilisé les
résultats donc sont donc très limités en
raison du des nombreux paliers qui
existent dans notre taxation je prends
l'exemple de la taxe britannique qui a
des taux d'indice plus élevés et
seulement trois paliers qui a permis de
réduire d'exemp par exemple et de la
proportion de boisson au-dessus du
premier seuil de 40 % soit un effet quat
fois supérieur à la taxe française donc
par conséquence le présent amendement
vise à réformer la taxe soda en passant
à trois tranches et en augmentant le
taux d'indice sur le même modèle et une
fois n'est pas coutume de nos amis
britanniques merci merci le 80 rectifié
TER Monsieur
Bonhomme merci Monsieur président
monsieur le ministre dans le même sens
cet
amendement vise à compléter à renforcer
surtout euh la modulation la taxe sur
les soda en fonction du taux de sucre
qui avait été voté et renforcé en 2018
dans le
PLFSS nous le savons nous connaissons
tous les effets d'une surconsommation de
sucre sur un de pathologie de
pathologies sévèr je pense évidemment
euh au cancer notamment du pancréas je
pense au diabète de type 2 4 millions2
de personnes touchées
euh avec plus tous ceux qui s'ignorent
diabétique je pense aussi aux maladies
cardiovasculaires aux avc bref des
pathologies sévères qui ont un coût
social terrible on évalue de l'ordre de
12 milliards d'euros le coût social plus
j'allais dire les pathologies associées
les
complications DMLA enfin on peut
vraiment dresser une liste toutes les
nuits et les qu'on peut avoir avec une
surconsommation de sucre alors cette
évidemment cette surtaxation cette cette
taxe renforcée s'inscrit dans une
politique de prévention vous avez av dit
c'est pas la politique de prévention moi
je considère que cette taxe
nutritionnelle alors c'est une un
sous-groupe de des taxes
comportementales s'inscrit totalement
d'une politique de prévention parce que
figurez-vous qu'entre-temps euh le
Conseil des prélèvements obligatoires a
évalué la taxation et notamment par
rapport au nos pays européens et comme
ça a été dit par mon collègue le cas
britannique est significatif et qui
relève vraiment des baisses de
consommation de taux de sucre puisque
c'est l'objectif de la taxation c'est
baisser le taux de sucre dans les dans
les dans dans les produits qui sont
soumis soda à consommation et c'est
aussi donc réduire les consommations
parce que l'effet prix on le sait on le
sait sur ce type de public a une effit
de réalité a une conséquence donc c'est
le sens de mon amendement avec une
augmentation significative de la taxe en
fonction du taux de
sucre l'amendement 516 rectifié qui
est-ce qu' le
défend monsieur
grosvallet
il est
défendu le 1004 rectifié monsieur Dosu
oui ça va dans le même sens que mes deux
ou trois précédents collègues donc on
voit qu'on arrive à à avoir une une un
consensus transpartisant mais je
voudrais revenir sur ce qu'a dit
monsieur le ministre sur la facteur prix
sur les les la fiscalité comportementale
sur le le tabac l'État a pris ses
responsabilité on a mis une taxation
dissuasive qui est révaluée interval
régulier des images des slogans
dissuisifes sur l'emballage 80 % du prix
final du tabac est constitué de taxe et
d'asscise et finalement on a le volume
de vente du tabac a été divisé par 2
depuis les années 90 et le taux de
mortalité a baissé aussi dit au concert
du pomon a baissé et donc c'est la même
approche que que mes précédents
collègues sur la taxe sur les boissons
sucré puisqu'on propose que cette taxe
soit doublée que aujourd'hui c'est une
taxe qui en gros s'élève à moins de 1500
de litre par litre de boisson et donc en
la doublant on on espère changer les les
comportements et nous espérons que cette
taxe sera réévalué régulièrement et donc
voilà c'est une taxe assez simple et qui
en plus permettra de financer les
campagnes de
prévention merci avis de la commission
madame la rapporteur générale
oui merci pour tous ces amendements hein
qui se penchent sur euh un fléo on
pourrait le dire hein euh euh qui est
justement la consommation de trop de
sucre
et je pense que la réduction des risques
en tout cas sur ce sujet-là elle est
évidente parce que c'est comme vous
l'avez dit les uns et les autres ce sont
des des maladies qui sont qui deviennent
chroniques des pathologies importantes
et qui sont aussi des facteurs
socialement mal vécus hein l'obésité par
exemple ça a des conséquences sur la
santé mentale aussi des jeunes et des
moins jeunes d'ailleurs et on voit bien
tous ces régimes qui font voilà
euh en quelque sorte maigrir mais
regrossir maigrir et regrossir enfin qui
font jouer au yoyo et et c'est très
mauvais pour la santé on le sait on on
on on a dans dans nos entourages
malheureusement euh voilà des exemples
qui nous font penser que ce n'est pas
très bon pour la santé or effectivement
on parle de santé quand on parle du
PLFSS en fait le produit prévisionnel de
cette taxe est de 453 millions d'euros
en 2024 c'est peu mais c'est aussi
important c'est aussi important parce
que justement il faut agir et agir sur
ce plan-là comme il faut agir sur le
plan de la communication mais je dirais
surtout sur le plan de l'éducation il
faut qu'à l'école très très jeune on
parle de l'alimentaire de ce qu'on met
dans l'assiette et c'est très très
important et et donc ça peut aider à
financer des campagnes éducative et et
de communication je pense que dès lors
que on on on rend une fiscalité enfin je
je pense qu'elle est pas punitive au
contraire on prolonge la vie des gens à
travers les les campagne qu'on peut
faire de communication et et d'éducation
c'est pas punitif c'est c'est c'est
quelque chose qui est bon pour la santé
mais c'est surtout que quand on lui
donne finalement un fléchage social
parce que je le rappelle he sur le plan
de la psychologie enfin c'est c'est la
santé mentale ça a des répercussions sur
la vie des familles ça a des
répercussions donc donc quand on flèche
en fait c'est important donc nous on a
demandé en fait au niveau de la
commission l'avis du Gouvernement
voilà avis du gouvernement monsieur le
ministre merci merci Monsieur le le
président quelques quelques remarques
d'abord vous savez que le gouvernement
enfin notre majorité en 2018 a a
procéder une révision du révision du
barem
importante je crois mais soit avec un
soutien très très large et je pense que
que c'est heureux comme
ça mais qu'il y a aussi une
préoccupation qu'il faut partager ici
c'est la question du poir d'achat et des
effets des mesures que l'on vote sur sur
le prix des le prix des produits donc on
est mais si la si si si la solution
était très simple je pense qu'on on
l'aurait tous prise d'un d'un commun
accord on voit bien qu'on est aussi
partagé entre ces équilibres là
c'est-à-dire à quel point je suis désolé
la fiscalité peut devenir punitive
punitive au sens du pouvoir d'achat et
le fait qu'on a des objectifs de de
politique publique bien entendu nous
nous sommes en attente d'un rapport euh
avec un consortium certains d'entre vous
l'ont évoqué dans leurs exposés des
motifs sur les effets de la taxation des
produits sucrés depuis la réforme de de
2018 c'est le projet soda taxe
qui mais monsieur le sénateur monsieur
le sénateur autant vous dire que je
n'écris pas moi-même ce rapport comme
vous en doutez et que ce rapport c'est
un rapport d'évaluation et que pour
évaluer il faut un peu de recul et que
pour évaluer on s'appuie sur des
universitaires donc je leur transmettrai
votre incitation aller plus vite mais
mais mais soyons quand même sérieux ben
l'évaluation oui il faut quelques années
pour évaluer les réformes des politiques
public 2018 on est en 2023 c'est le
temps aussi des fois nécessaire pour
mesurer l'impact de ce que l'on fait
donc moi je considère qu'on a besoin de
prendre connaissance de ce rapport pour
savoir quelles sont les conséquences des
réformes que nous avons voté en 2018
pour éventuellement adapter adapter le
le barem c'est la raison pour laquelle
j'aurais demande selon les amendements
soit de retrait soit défavorable voilà
pour les extraits de la séance le Sénat
qui examine le projetcement de la
sécurité sociale depuis lundi pour en
parler j'accueille ici ellisabeth
douanau bonjour bonjour Quentin c'est
vous la rapporteur générale de ce PLFSS
comme on dit vous allez pouvoir nous
aider à comprendre un peu toutes les
subtilités de ce texte et de la version
que le Sénat veut modifier mais déjà un
mot sur le contexte dans lequel vous
examinez ce projet de loi de financement
de la sécurité sociale il a été adopté
avec 493 à l'Assemblée nationale ça
signifie que et bien vous avez la copie
directe du gouvernement les députés qui
ne sont pas allés au-delà de l'article 8
dans ce projet de loi est-ce que c'est
une bonne chose ou est-ce que c'est une
mauvaise chose puisque'à la fin le
gouvernement pourrait aussi tout
réécrire avec le 493 écoutez rien n'a
changé depuis l'anne dernière dernière
parce que c'était absolument la même
chose on avait pas tous les articles non
plus dans le texte qui avait été
présenté par le gouvernement ici au
Sénat donc on s'habitue mais on
s'habitue à de mauvaises façons en
réalité il faut aussi respecter un
certain temps pour l'examen du PLFSS on
avait d'ailleurs eu ce débat lors de la
loi pour la réforme des retraites parce
que le gouvernement avait choisi ce mode
finalement de présentation parce que le
temps est limité donc on voit bien que
le débat enfin le texte arrive en partie
et que le débat est certainement un peu
tronqué on vous a entendu très inquiète
à la tribune sur le trou de la SQ parce
qu'il se creuse le déficit est estimé à
8,8 milliards en 2023 11,2 milliards en
2024 17,5 milliards d'euros en 2025 on
voit ces chiffres qui s'affichent cette
trajectoire vous avez trouvé ça
inquiétant n'est-ce pas je trouve ça
inquiétant parce qu'en fait on ne
s'interroge pas comment on rembourse la
dette et comment on maîtrise les
dépenses donc moi je pense qu'il y a un
vrai travail à faire sur la perte
performance en fait et de
l'investissement des dépenses finalement
du fonctionnement d' l' ensemble
d'établissements et cette idée de de de
de présenter une trajectoire qui est de
plus en plus déficitaire est un
renoncement c'est un aveu d'impuissance
c'est-à-dire qu'en fait on on demandera
aux générations futures de payer
finalement nos consultations et nos
actes de santé comment expliquer que le
trou de la SQ continue de se creuser que
les Français ne voit pas d'amélioration
dans l'accès aux soins dans les déserts
médicaux comment on explique ce ce ce
cette dicotomie en fait déjà moi je
voudrais parler de finalement de ces
déficit moi je pense que les Français se
sont habitué au trous de la SCU parce
que qui n'a pas entendu parler du trou
de la S exactement en 2019 nous étions
quasiment à l'équilibre et nous étions
montés d'ailleurs de situations assez
catastrophique après nous avons vécu la
crise sanitaire et c'était tout à fait
normal que la sécurité sociale Vienne
finalement en terme de protection auprès
des français auprès des entreprises
auprès des familles mais là en fait la
TRA trajectoire qui est proposée elle
sera de plus en plus déficitaire
pourquoi parce que justement on voit que
l'assurance maladie coûte de plus en
plus cher alors que les Français sont de
plus en plus insatisfaits donc c'est
pour ça que je dis qu'il faut interroger
la performance de la dépense il faut
aussi lutter contre les fraudes c'est
important éviter les actes redondants en
fait il faut tout interroger interroger
aussi les niches sociales parce que hier
on a eu un grand débat sur justement
tous les allègements que l'onah qui sont
demandés par un certain nombre de
filières par exemple exemple voilà comme
la la filière
viticol moi je je comprends bien et je
suis très attentive à ce que chacun s'en
sorte le mieux qui qu'il soit mais les
exonérations les niches sociales il faut
y faire quand même très attention parce
que hier le peu qui ont été voté c'est
quand même 1 milliard 3 on va voir
d'autres modifications de la droite et
du centre vous voulez le report de la de
la réforme sur la tarification à
l'activité la fameuse T2A vous n'en
voulez pas immédiatement vous voulez que
et bien cette réforme soit remise à 2028
suite après une expérimentation autre
modification que vous voulez c'est la
consultation du Parlement en cas
d'augmentation des franchises médicales
on sait que ça avait été mis sur la
table à l'été dernier et enfin on voit
une troisième modification vous voulez
mettre en place une taxe lapin lorsque
et bien un patient ne se rend pas un
rendez-vous médical sur la tarification
à l'acte pourquoi est-ce que vous êtes
aussi prudent alors écoutez ça fait
longtemps qu'on dénonce en fait de ne
payer finalement ou en tout cas de
financer l'hôpital sur son activité mais
que sur euh euh la quantité il faut euh
évidemment regarder si l'hôpital
s'engage justement je disais tout à
l'heure dans la performance de la
dépense s'il s'engage sur euh des
éléments de coordination avec la
médecine de ville en fait il y a tout un
ensemble de propositions qui pourraient
être euh fait au aux établissements pour
justement travailler sur la qualité en
fait et non plus que sur la quantité
donc pourquoi être contre et bien on est
contre parce qu'en fait on a eu
tellement peu d'explications dans le
texte il il est assez creux on nous
parle de forfait de santé publique on
nous parle voilà de forfait de
coordination mais c'est assez vague en
fait et c'est un travail pourtant qui a
été démarré il y a quelques temps déjà
mais nous n'avions pas beaucoup
d'éléments après vous me parlez de la
taxe la page je l'avais proposé avec
Corine Humber l'année dernière qui est
la rapporteur de la branche maladie
parce que 10 % des rendez-vous médicaux
oui parce que ça il faut le dénoncer il
faut il faut il y a tellement de de de
personnes qui cherchent un médecin
traitant et qui se trouent bloqué par
des gens qui vont prendre des
rendez-vous et ne vont pas euh y aller
on va terminer avec d'autres
modifications il nous reste une minute
on voit aussi le fait que vous ne voulez
pas des médicaments à l'unité en cas de
rupture ou encore des médicaments à base
de cannabis vous vous demandez d'abord
l'avis de la Haute Autorité de Santé
pourquoi est-ce que les médicaments à
l'unité c'est une mauvaise idée ça peut
être une bonne idée si vous voulez quand
on réfléchit comme ça on se dit bah oui
il y a tellement de gens qui sortent
avec des sacs de médicaments de la
pharmacie et finalement qui restent dans
le placard ça on est d'accord moi je
pense que maintenant il faut que euh
quand on passe chez le médecin en
consultation il faut absolument que le
médecin mais je pense qu'ils le font de
plus en plus souvent c'est que en fait
il préconiseent tant de boîtes avec tant
de cachets parce que en fait le problème
c'est le conditionnement or c'est des
chaînes en fait de production vous
rendez compte qu'il faut complètement
changer et donc ça peut se faire sur
certains médicaments mais pas d'autres
par exemple sur les sirop pédiatriques
qui ont beaucoup manqué et bien on ne
peut pas le faire enfin on peut pas
présenter des cuirés de de de sirop à
l'unité donc on on étudie ça je pense
que l'industrie pharmaceutique étudie ça
mais pour l'instant ça paraît encore un
petit peu prématuré et bien merci merci
Elisabeth don pour toutes ces
explications au micro de publicsenat on
continuera à suivre notamment sur
publicsenat.fr à la fin de l'examen de
ce texte
merci on en vient au troisième thème
dans cette émission et les dirigeants de
l'Agence France Presse qui était reçu
mardi au Sénat l'agence avec Reuters et
Associated Press l'une des plus grandes
agences de presse au monde mais
l'utilisation du terme terroriste pour
évoquer le Hamas entre guillemets dans
les dépêches a suscité l'incompréhension
les dirigeants de la FP s'en sont
expliqués cette semaine au Sénat tout en
racontant également les conditions de
travail des journalistes sur le terrain
ils sont SEP dans la bande de Gaza on
écoute on y revient juste après avec une
invité la FP prend très au sérieux les
accusations de biais dont elle fait
l'objet d'abord parce que son statut
voté en 1957 à l'unanimité du Parlement
après un long combat pour l'indépendance
de l'agence dispose c'est son article 2
qu'elle ne peut en aucune circonstance
tenir compte d'influence ou de
considération de nature à compromettre
l'exactitude ou l'objectivité de
l'information ensuite on le prend très
au sérieux parce que ce n'est pas de
n'importe quel biais qu'il s'agit la
plupart des critiques en France évoquent
un biais proalestinien mais certains
n'ont pas pas hésiter à faire de
l'agence un vecteur de la montée de
l'antisémitisme c'est d'autant plus
grave et infamant que l'AFP est né en
août 1944 à la
Libération grâce à l'action d'une
poignée de résistant bientôt rejoint par
des rescapés de la Choa pour mettre fin
à la propagande et la censure imposée
par l'occupant nazi à l'office français
d'information alors en place ces
accusations sont folles elles ne sont
pas que des propos de plateau de
télévision puisqu'un élu de la
République un député les a reprises à
son
compte les accusations sont parfois
outrancières mais vous avez raison
monsieur le Président le débat sur la
couverture du conflit lui et tout ce
qu'il y a de plus légitime et
attendu toutes les grandes rédactions
aujourd'hui sont secoué par des
discussions internes parfois vives et
laafp n'y échappe pas philchetwin à mes
côtés qui est directeur de l'information
de l'agence est en relation étroite avec
ses pères des grands médias
internationaux et tous disent que c'est
la couverture la plus complexe et
sensible qu'ils ont eu à organiser
depuis qu'ils sont en
poste ce n'est pas surprenant prenez le
sujet géopolitique le plus complexe et
chargé de passion qui soit ajouter
l'effet de sidération de l'attaque du 7
d' octobre mélanger avec ces symptômes
bien connus de nos sociétés
contemporaines que sont la polarisation
des esprits l'hystérisation du débat la
prévalence de la société du Commentaire
offrez le bien sûr la caisse de
résonance des réseaux sociaux et des
émissions où ça clashe et vous obtenez
un cocktail des plus
explosifs la polémique qui nous touche
est né d'un article de presse qui se
scandalisait de ce que l'agence ne
qualifie pas le mass de groupes
terroristes en n'appelant pas un chat un
chat l'agence révélait ses noirs
penchants habilement l'article laissait
entendre qu'une nouvelle consigne venait
d'être donnée en interne de proscrire
l'usage du mot s'agissant du Hamas comme
s'il s'agissait donc d'une consigne sur
mesure ce que l'article ne disait pas
c'est que cette consigne avait plus de
20 ans qu'elle s'appliquait à tous les
mouvements sans exception Boko Haram est
islamique Al-Qaïda j'en passe et que
d'ailleurs au passage la FP n'était pas
seule à appliquer cette règle puisque
les deux grands grands les deux autres
grands acteurs qui font le même métier
qu'elle la société de presse et res
suivent exactement les mêmes règles
alors il est facile de moquer la
réflexion éditoriale sérieuse qui a
présidé à l'élaboration de cette règles
en l'assimilant aux discussions
byzantines sur le sexe des anges c'est
tout simplement refuser de chercher à
comprendre ce qu'est le métier d'une
agence on aurait pu s'interroger sur un
biais si la règle avait été changée pour
ce cas
précis pas dans le cas contraire et
j'ajoute à l'intention de tous ceux qui
continuent de manifester leur
incompréhension supposons je dis bien
supposons parce que ça ne nous a jamais
effleuré l'esprit que nous renoncions à
cette consigne
éditoriale
sous la pression des commentateurs ou
d'un certain camp politique que
dirait-on alors là oui on serait fondé à
parler d'une agence sous
influence depuis cette polémique pas un
jour ne passe sans qu'il faille répondre
à une nouvelle
interpellation
parfois la critique est fondée et
l'agence n'a absolument aucun problème à
reconnaître des choix éditoriaux
discutables elle l'a fait publiquement
oui elle aurait dû rendre compte le jour
même d'une projection organisée par les
autorités israéliennes sur les atrocité
du 7 octobre elle l'a fait en anglais
pas en français cela a un nom ça
s'appelle un raté qui n'en fait
pas parfois les attaques font sourire
samedi matin je reçois d'un ami un sms
me poussant un tweet et me disant juste
bon courage ce tweet d'un exjournaliste
dont je terrai le nom par charité disait
vous vous demandez pourquoi la FP refuse
d'employer le mot terroriste au sujet du
Hamas voici peut-être un élément de
réponse Phil chetwin directeur de
l'information à lafp était ou est encore
membre du collectif photographers for
Palestine dont le but est de raconter
l'histoire de la Palestine telle que
vécu aujourd'hui philch twin écrit dans
des revues comme electronic Intifada et
prêche dans des mosquées écossaises il a
fallu une journée pour convaincre ce
journaliste que fil avait un homonyme
entreetemps le tweet avait gagné
plusieurs dizaines de milliers de
suiveurs mais il arrive que les coups de
sonde pour voir soi
grave ils peuvent menacer alors
physiquement des
personnes vendredi dernier tous les
grands médias internationaux New York
Times CNN rter associéé de presse et
AFP ont dû se défendre de l'accusation
que certains de leur photographe de Gaza
était en réalité au courant de l'attaque
et l'avait documenté non pas comme
journaliste donc mais comme complice
notre rédaction en chef a passé la
matinée à contrôleré toutes les photos
prises par nos journalistes le 7 à
regarder l'heure et le lieu d'où elles
avaient été prises autant de temps pris
sur la couverture naturellement nous
avons dû expliquer que nos trois
photographes installés à Gaza qui
travaillent de façon permanente pour
lafp parfois depuis plus de 20 ans qui
sont reconnus par des pris
internationaux se sont mobilisés dès que
l'attaque du Hamas a été connue ils ont
été réveillés par des tirs d'artillerie
et de roquettes se sont rendus alors à
proximité de la barrière entre Gaza et
Israël chacun était identifié clairement
comme journaliste sur son casque et son
gilet par balle les premières photos à
proximité de la barrière de Gaza ont été
réalisé plus d'une heure après le début
de l'attaque bref ils n'ont fait que le
métier suivent l'événement à mesure
qu'il se déroulait sur le terrain tous
les autres médias attaqués ont pu
montrer comme nous qui n'était en rien
coupable de ce qu'on leur reprochait
mais il a fallu 3 jours à l'organisation
qui avait lancé l'affaire pour
reconnaître que celle-ci était close
d'une phase phrase lapidaire en
prétendant qu'elle n'avait fait que
poser des questions et qu'elle avait été
mal comprise entreettemps le mal était
fait les noms de ces photographes
avaient été jetés en pâture l'espace
d'une journée ils ont été considérés
comme terroristes et alors que nous
cherchons tous les moyens les évacuer
vous imaginez que cela ne va pas nous
aider dans nos démarches pour qu'ils
intègrent la liste des quelques
chanceux c'est l'occasion pour moi de
dire que si jamais il arrivait un
malheur à l'un quelconque de nos neuf
salariés à Gaza cela susciterait au sein
de l'agence la même émotion que celle
que nous avons connu à l'occasion de la
mort du français Arman soldine en mai
dernier
ou de la grave blessure de notre jeune
photographe libanaise Christina assis
touché par un tir au Sud Liban il y a
quelques
semaines parce qu'il participe autant
que n'importe quel autre salarié à
l'exercice de la mission d'intérêt
général de l'Agence et même probablement
davantage au vu de la difficulté de
témoigner de ce qui se passe à
Gaza sachez pour finir que cette
polémique sur le BIA proalestinien prêté
à lafp est purement française qu'on ne
la retrouve nulle part ailleurs elle
sidère nos équipes dans la région
habituées à entendre plutôt que notre
agence fait le jeu
d'Israël nous avons reçu beaucoup de
messages privés d'encouragement
notamment nos clients mais je note qu'il
y a eu très peu d'expression publique de
soutien au travail de lafp probablement
pour ne pas être mêlé à une querelle
incandescente comme il paraît qu'on n
jamais mieux servi que par soi-même
vous me permettrez peut-être que je dise
tout simplement qui d'autre qui d'autre
que l'AFP emploie 50 journalistes textes
photos vidéos à Jérusalem Gaza et ramala
qui d'autre parvenait encore jusqu'à
samedi à envoyé seul des images de
gazaville qui d'autre a diffusé depuis
le 7 octobre 242 reportages je ne parle
pas de simple factuel mais de vraies
histoires uite dont 96 depuis Israël 53
depuis Gaza et les territoires
occupés qui d'autre pour ne prendre que
quelques reportages de ce matin a
raconté l'histoire de ces jeunes d'un
kibou se ravager qui retournent à
l'école après les enterrements où
interviewit le créateur de la série Foda
expliquant pourquoi la guerre à Gaza
avait dépasser tous les
scénarios Maurice Levy a écrit une très
belle tribune intitulée jamais depuis la
Choa la communauté juif de France ne
s'était senti aussi isolée évoquant les
40 Français juifs assassiné le 7 il
écrit qui étaient ces 40 français quelle
était leur vie étai-ils parents on ne
sait rien d'eux parce que l'on ne veut
rien savoir ni leur nom ni leurs âges ni
leur vie ni leur visage laafp a commencé
de raconter la vie de certaines de ses
victimes grâce à son réseau de
journalistes en contact régulier à avec
des familles d'otage et de la presse
israélienne
elle est parvenue hier à identifier 208
des 239 otages recensés par les
autorités
elle a décompté au moins 34 enfants dont
17 de moins de 10 ans l'otage le plus
jeune est un nourrisson âgé de 9 mois
enlevé dans le kibut nirose avec son
frère Ariel 4 ans et ses parents de
jeunes trentenair h octogéires figurent
parmi les
captifs qui d'autre que lafp a fait ce
travail dans le passé c'était toujours
possible de mettre des des renforts à
Gaza pour pour des autres conflits
guerres et cetera cette foisci c'est pas
possible normalement on est on a neu
staff en total à Gaza il inclus se
journalistes et bien sûr c'est c'est
important d'avoir des autres à côté
d'eux des gens qui viennent ou de
Jérusalem ou ou d'ailleurs pour pour les
aider pour les renforcer pour les guider
dans des moments très difficiles et de
montrre aussi que l'agence avec eux à ce
moment qui qui est difficile
eu si on a réussi
jusqu'ici de de de faire notre boulot
là-bas c'est c'est vraiment cette
mélange de journistes israélien qu'on a
sur le terrain palestinien et étranger
c'est vraiment une équipe très très
mixte
eu en terme de conditions de travail
à ça dépend il y a bien sûr en Israël le
c'est la sécurité qui prime ça veut dire
que parfois c'est la question d'accès ça
se
négocie parfois on a besoin de
travailler avec les autorités pour avoir
accès et cetera mais mais bien sûr on
est allé partout dans toutes les
diffentes quiibout qui étaient affecté
toutes les les les les villes qui
étaient
affectées et on a une présence vraiment
dans tout le sud là toutes les images
qui donnent sur Gaza de Sidro par
exemple dans le sud même chose dans le
Nord ça ça se négocie ça dépend il y a
bien sûr une situation sécurité qui qui
est qui est considérable ça veut dire
queon peut pas juste aller n'importe où
mais euh ça ça c'est un peu notre boulot
de d'aller dans dans le maximum
différent endroit Dateline et cetera euh
à Gaza c'est autre chose euh c'est
extrêmement difficile nos journalistes
travaillent dans des situations très
très euh bah ils sont dans une précarité
extrême on a évacué notre bureau à Gaza
City parce que c'est c'était dans la
zone où les Israéliens nous a demandé
tout le monde de de de fuir on a évacué
notre bureau il y a 10 jours de semaines
euh je pense c'est bien connu que notre
bureau a souffert un frappe euh il y a
une semaine il y avait personne dedans
mais les les dommages sur le bâtiment
sont sont considérables euh nos
journalistes avec le famille euh en
total c'est 70%
euh sont dans des appartements détente
des des des des des situations très très
très difficiles dans dans le sud Gaza
euh ils font un boulot remarquable dans
les circonstances euh mais ils sont dans
une situation très très très précaire
notamment parce qu'il y avait des des
frappes qui continuent autour d'eux
certains ont perdu des des membres de
famille euh presque à la moitié ont
perdu le le résidence Le le
appartementou le maison euh mais il
continue de de de bosser faire un
travail remarquable avec le bureau de
Jérusalem il travaille jour à jour avec
le bureau de Jérusalem tout toute la
copie passe via le bureau de Jérusalem
il travaille très bien ensemble je vais
revenir sur la question des des des
chiffres utilisés par tous les gros
médias
euh de Gaza euh c'est les chiffres qui
viennent de l'autorité euh hospitalière
à Gaza bien sûr sous le contrôle de
Hamas sous l'administration de Hamas
euh il faut distinguer distinguer là que
Hamas il y a la partie militaire il y a
parti politique et puis il y a
l'administration les chiffres qui
viennent de partie de l'administration
notamment autour de de qui vienent des
hôpitaux et cetera sont considérés comme
fiables par l'ONU par les ONG qui
travaillent là-bas ils sont très
détaillés on a des des noms des nombres
de familles eu h après
euh il y a niveau de détail ils sont
utilisés dans les rapports
gouvernementals euh ils sont pas
énormément contestés par les Israéliens
eu je sais que c'est président Biden qui
a fait un commentaire là-dessus mais
c'était très intéressant que juste la
semaine il y a deux TR jours un membre
de l'équipe Biden a dit en fait
que il était on l' cité sur le fil de la
FP que le chiff est probablement
beaucoup trop bas en fait qu'il a des
gens sous les bâtiments et
cetera on a écrit des explications sur
comment on utilise ces chiffres je pense
les société de Press a fait la même
chose et je pense même les gens de l'ONU
a parlé depuis encore une fois sur la la
la fiabilité de ces chiffres bien sûr
parfois c'est ça ça ça va être dans une
situation comme on vit maintenant
parfois des estimations
mais ils sont largement considérés comme
fiables est-ce qu'on a la capacité de fa
checker sur le terrain toutes les ces
détails et cetera non là où on a des
problèmes et c'était écrit dans notre
copie dans les chiffres ils disent
jamais bien sûr qu' sont des combattant
euh il communique beaucoup sur la
quantité d'enfants à
c'est pas surprenant étant donné le le
le mix de la population il y a
énormément de jeunes qui visent à à
Gaza on peut pas être sûr de la quantité
mais tout ce que je peux dire c'est nos
gens les eux-mêmes dans les hôpitaux
dans les Morg dans la rue ont vu
certainement des centaines et des
centaines d'enfants blessés et et morts
je peux pas aller plus loin que que que
ça
euh mais comme j'ai dit c'est c'est
c'est ces chiffres sont sont utilisés
par par beaucoup beaucoup de médias
organisation euh les ONG et et et l'ONU
euh et c'est à cause de ça je pense que
on revient sur cette incident à à
l'hôpital
euh que beaucoup de médias a repris
cette info
euh il y avait encore une fois
différentes sources pour cette info sur
la frappe de l'hôpital il y avait un
communiqué qui vient de la partie
militaire de Hamas qu'on n pas touché
qui a parlé de de 500
morts il y a une communiqué qui vient de
système hospitalier qui qui a parlé de
je pense quelques centaines morts qu'on
a
repris sorcé c'était c'était comme on
fait asse souvent avec une allégation
c'était clairement sorcé à
l'administration médicale sous contrôle
de
Hamas alors
est-ce qu'on aura le luxe de ne pas
traiter cette info non parce que ça
partte c'est c'est c'est c'est sur
toutes les chaînes en boucle arabe c'est
sur les réseaux sociaux c'est notre
boulot d'y aller et de contextualiser et
et et et de faire notre boulot de de
vérification et
contextualisation on aurait dû être plus
prudent dans la manière dont on a on a
écrit La Dépêche on aurait dû être plus
ferme sur le fait que AFP était par sur
place que AFP était pas en mesure de
confirmer l'allégation de de Hamas parce
que c'était une allégation qui était
très
gros la formulation des mots était pas
parfait on a changé nos consignes après
pour juste changer la manière dont on
formule certaines choses qu on pas de de
Hamas eu et après la complexité c'était
euh l'attente pour pour vraiment la
partie israélienne on a eu une réaction
assez rapide des Israéliens qui dit on
est en train de de regarder mais ça a
pris 3h pour avoir le contreenarratif et
3h dans le temps réel et c'est toute la
complexité du travail de la FP c'est le
travail de temps réel 3h dans le temps
réel c'est c'est énorme c'est énorme
mais bien sûr dès qu'on a eu la réaction
israélienne on on a alerté on a on a
complètement changé la manière d'écrire
les dépêches on a on a on on a fait tout
euh mais c'est ce 3 He qui est qui est
qui est qui est compliqué
euh et c'est quelque chose que j'ai
discuté avec mes mes mes homologues àp
et et il y a pas une solution très
simple à ça parce que c'est c'est le
contexte dans lequel on travaille le
contexte des réseaux euh le contexte de
de de de voilà de l'information qu'
qu'on maîtrise pas c'est pas les agences
maintenant qui maîtriseent la diffusion
de l'info l'info parte immédiatement sur
les réseaux et après on chasse après
pour cont actualisé mais comme j'ai dit
on aurait dû l'écrire dans une manière
plus prudent est-ce que ça aurait changé
la narratif je suis pas convaincu mais
on sera plus ferme plus content chez
nous si si on a écrit différemment et si
ça passe une deuxème fois on la traite
différemment bonjour Monique dearco
sénatrice écologiste de la Gonde on
vient d'entendre ces dirigeants de
l'Agence France Presse qui était reçu au
Sénat c'était C semaine dans le contexte
d'une polémique qui a été longuement
abordée sur son traitement du conflit
entre Israël et le Hamas la FP qui
n'utilise pas le terme terroriste ou
alors entre guillemets l'agence explique
que c'est une disposition de longue date
conforme aux politiques rédactionnelles
des autres agences de presse
internationale qu'est-ce que vous avez
pensé de cette polémique et des
explications hier en séance écoutez moi
j'ai suivi cette polémique effectivement
je m'étais beaucoup interrogé parce que
le terme terroriste éétait quelque chose
qui me venait évidemment de fait sur ce
qui se passait politiquement c'était
très important d'employer ce terme là ce
termel on le voit il faut l'employer il
faut savoir l'employer et ne affirmer
qu'il y a un problème de terrorisme avec
le Hamas sauf que donc ceci la FP a été
justement critiqué pour ne pas avoir
employé ce terme entre guillemets et
cetera donc c'était bien qu'il y ait
cette audition avec le président de la
FP ainsi que directeur parce qu'ils ont
su expliquer comment comment ils
faisaient leur travail c'est-à-dire
qu'en définitive il y avait une charte
qui était respectée également par
d'autres agences comme re et AA qui ce
terme làé de presse ou voilà n'était pas
un terme qu'ils utilisaient que ils
s'adressaient pas non plus c'est très
important parce que j'avais besoin de
comprendre aussi la démarche qu'il
s'adressaient pas directement au tout
public mais il s'adressait à des médias
et c'était aux médias de pouvoir
transporter un petit peu les propos
qu'ils écrivaient vousz des images
également des vidéos voilà donc euh ça
permis quand même une clarification tout
à fait les les rédactions sont abonnées
au fil de la FP tout comme Public Sénat
d'ailleurs nous disposons d'images
envoyé par l'agence et aussi de dépêche
que l'on pouvit reprendre pour notre
travail effectivement la FP ne donne pas
de de contenu explicite pour le public
alors selon la FP tout est une question
aussi de contexte d'utilisation du terme
de terroriste la FP qui précise aussi
refuser de qualifier des mouvements
groupes ou individus de terroriste sans
attribuer directement l'utilisation de
ce mot ou ou sans utiliser des
guillemets ça aussi c'est c'est
compliqué à comprendre mais la FP
travaille de façon très méticuleuse
c'est bien ça alors oui nous expliqué en
définitive aussi ils souhaitent protéger
également leurs correspondants locaux et
pour eux c'est très important parce que
comme vous le savez ils ont une
cinquantaine de correspondants locaux
pour couvrir le le problème Gaza Israël
et et dans d'autres pays d'autres
circonstances ils ont besoin donc de de
protéger leur correspondant donc ils
évitent aussi de d'employer certains
termes mais cette clarification me
paraissait tout à fait essentielle
nécessaire parce que je sentais que
cette polémique commence à augmenter sur
cette période là avec ce terme-là et je
j'espère que ça a coupé tout court à
toute polémique concernant leur travail
autre source de polémique le fait que
l'agence reprenne les décomptes des
chiffres du ministère de la Santé et
donc les chiffres du Hamas là-dessus les
dirigeants de la FP ont dit les chiffres
partagés par les autorités
administratives du Hamas sont considérés
comme comme fiable par l'ONU et les ONG
qui travaillent sur place ils sont très
détaillés on a des noms de famille ils
ne sont pas énormément contestés par les
autorités israéliennes ça vous a
convaincu là encore alors écoutez moi
c'est pareil j'attendais des
explications la façon dont ils ont
formulé oou l' expliqué son travail et
cetera m'a m'a convaincu ouais et on
termine avec une dernière question la FP
qui est revenue sur les difficultés des
SEP journalistes qui sont présents à
Gaza dans la bande de Gaza sont coupé du
monde ils travaillent dans une précarité
extrême on dit les dirigeants de la FP
c'est un fort de l'audition parce que en
plus les bureaux de la FP ont été
touchés par des frappes c'était le 2
novembre dernier il y a pas eu de
victime mais les locaux sont gravement
détruit c'est des conditions de travail
très particulières pour l'Agence France
Presse donc je crois que là ils sont ils
ont dit d'ailleurs que c'était le pire
conflit qu'ils avaient à couvrir depuis
très longtemps que les conditions
étaient exécrables que c'était
extrêmement difficile de faire remonter
les informations et donc je pense que
qu'effectivement et puis également ils
ont été le président a été voir donc s
rendu directement au Liban aussi
conforter et rendre visite à des
reporters qui ont été blessés pendant
les conflits donc on sent quand même
qu'il y a une grande émotion et que ce
travail qui est effectué se fait avec
grande difficulté donc c'est pour ça
qu'il faut conforter quand même et
éviter à mon sens de de critiquer de
cette façonlà le travail de la FP qui
est un travail remarquable et bien merci
c'est sur ces mots un travail remarqu c
que se termine cette interview
effectivement on salue nos confrères de
la
FP pour terminer cette émission on finit
sur un zoom sur les travaux de la
commission d'enquête sur les agressions
envers les professeurs 3 ans après
l'attentat qui a coûté la vie à Samuel
paatti les sénateurs planchent sur le
sujet de la responsabilité et le travail
du gouvernement en matière de soutien
aux enseignants une mission qui résonne
également avec l'assassinat de Dominique
Bernard à haras il y a quelques semaines
les sénateurs qui recevaient cette
semaine Stanislas Guerini le ministre de
la Fonction publique on l'écoute on y
revient juste après avec un invité la
mission de contrôle que vous effectuez
je crois est évidemment liée à des
actualités dramatiques et je le dis en
ayant une pensée évidemment pour la
famille de de Dominique Bernard et suite
au drame
d'aras et au-delà sur les agressions les
menaces et parfois les le pire
c'està-dire des assassinats que vivent
nos agents public dans l'ensemble des
services publics et j'élargis en en
introduisant cette cette commission mon
propos aux agents publics qui ces
derniers mois et sur cette année ont été
assassinés dans l'exercice de leur
fonction je pense à agès LAL professeur
à saint-jean- de luuse assassiné dans
l'exercice des ses fonctions je pense à
Ludovique Montuel agent de la DG FIP et
à sa collègue qui a été séquestré DEC
Montuel a été assassiné dans l'exercice
de ses fonctions
je pense à Karen mzino infirmière à
l'hôpital à mes qui a elle aussi été
assassinée dans l'exercice de ses
fonctions et au-delà de de ces agents
publics assassinés je crois que la
situation elle concerne en réalité des
milliers des dizaines de milliers
d'agents publics qui sont
quotidiennement menacés agressés
violentés dans tous les lieux de service
public derrière tous les guichets de
service public et j'ai souhaité
m'engager de façon très transversale au
fond parce que je crois que quand
parfois nous sommes réunis pour parler
d'attractivité de la fonction publique
pour parler de son efficacité je crois
que la la première considération au fond
qu'on doit aux agents publics c'est de
les mettre dans les bonnes situations
pour exercer leur mission et donc
l'enjeu de protection de protection
physique c'est un enjeu qui est
absolument central et qui doit nous
mobiliser absolument et donc je voudrais
dans dans mon propos avoir une approche
transversale qui souhaite que celle que
j'ai souhaité installer dans toutes les
administrations elle doit être
évidemment décliné et approfondie
sectoriellement si je puis dire vous
recevrez évidemment mon mon collègue
ministre de l'éducation nationale de la
jeunesse Gabriel Atal c'est vrai aussi
dans le champ de la santé Agnès firmain
le Baudeau a mené un travail important a
missionné des personnalités qualifiées
pour travailler à ces questions dans le
champ de l'hôpital dans le champ de de
de la santé c'est vrai au fond dans
toutes les administrations et au fond
j'élargirai même à tous les opérateurs
avec des agents qui sont pas forcément
des agents fonctionnaires titulaires au
contractuel mais qui sont délégataires
de service public et ces derniers mois
c'était avant l'été j'ai j'ai réuni pour
la première fois un comité installé un
Comité pour la protection des agents
publics en réunissant à la fois des
administrations mais aussi des
opérateurs je pense à Pôle emploi je
pense à la CAF je pense à la CNAM je
pense à la knave je pense à la poste euh
pour essayer de voir comment est-ce
qu'on pourrait mutualiser au fond les
initiatives les approches et on se rend
compte d'ailleurs que ces réseaux-là ne
se parlent pas suffisamment de tout ce
qui pourrait mettre en commun euh il y a
des initiatives qui sont très
intéressantes la knaf a par exemple
déployé un outil de recensement en ligne
qui permet à chaque agent de signaler
une agression immédiatement la Poste a
diffusé un guide sur le dépôt de plainte
pour accompagner les agents dans cette
démarche bref je pense qu'on a un enjeu
de partage d'expérience et de
mutualisation qui qui est très important
euh je je je crois que les drames des
derniers mois doivent nous amener à
lutter avec d'autant plus de vigueur
contre les les agressions que tout ceci
joue aussi sur le rapport avec les
usagers et et et crée un sentiment
d'agressivité parfois qui n'est pas bon
pour service public à la fin et on doit
avoir un regard le plus lucide possible
je dis ça en essayant de qualifier les
faites d'abord avec humilité vous m'avez
invité à dire toute la vérité la réalité
c'est que on mesure mal aujourd'hui ces
phénomènes là on les mesure de façon
parcellaire j'ai quelques chiffres à
indiquer qui sont déjà parlants 35000
agressions de professionnel de santé
remonté en 2021
35000 12000 actes d'incivilité remontés
par les caisses d'allocation familiale
en 2022 pour vous donner quelques
exemples mais nous avons aujourd'hui une
difficulté j'y reviendrai à bien mesurer
et on peut être d'ors et déjà certain
qu'il y a une forme de allo autour de
ces chiffres là sur les remontées qui
sont effectiv et effectué ce qui est
certain quand on réunit les réseaux les
administrations tout le monde fait le
même constat il y a à la fois un enjeu
sur le nombre d'agression mais il y a
aussi un enjeu sur l'intensité des
agressions que vivent les agents
d'ailleurs j'ai décidé de bannir le mot
incivilité de mon vocabulaire quand je
parlais de ces sujets là je me suis
rendu compte à quel point il était
parfois contreproductif ce n'est pas des
incivilités que vivent les agents
publics ce sont des menaces et des
agressions la réalité c'est qu'il y a
quelques années on pouvait se dire que
on commence par un dialogue un peu hrité
puis ça se terminit par des menaces
aujourd'hui tous les réseaux nous
remontent le fait que on démarre plutôt
par des menaces et parfois on va au pire
à des agressions à des cûts ou parfois
au drames que j'ai évoqué en
introduisant et au fond ça montre qu'il
y a des causes exogènes et que les
services publics voient un certain
nombre de dérives de notre société
derrière les cas dramatiques que j'ai
mentionné sont parfois des sujets de
santé mental la professeur à Saint-Jean
Luse c'était pas un cas de
radicalisation c'était un enjeu de santé
mentale parfois c'est le fait du
terrorisme de l'islamisme qui a touché
nos agents publics toutes les dérives de
notre société qui déferent et puis il
faut aussi avoir la lucidité de
constater qu'il y a parfois des causes
endogènes je le dis parce que c'est ce
que nous remontent nos administrations
parfois des agents placés dans des
situations de devoir appliquer des
démarches administratives trop complexes
pas assez lisibles d'être mis dans des
mauvais mauvaises conditions tout ça
crée aussi un sentiment d'irritation qui
peut ensuite arriver à l'agressivité
c'est le téléphone qui est pas décroché
c'est des temps d'attente très longs et
quand on on discute notamment dans le
secteur hospitalier les agents publics
nous le disent parfois des agents des
des des patients qui ont attendu pendant
9h aux urgences bah oui ils sont dans
des situations où l'agressivité vient
plus vite et donc ça montre à quel point
il faut prendre ce sujet avec humilité
mais aussi travailler sur toutes les
causes
y compris les causes racines de notre
propre complexité administrative si on
veut essayer de de de pouvoir progresser
alors j'ai présenté en septembre un plan
de protection des agents publics avec un
fil rouge qui est de ne jamais laisser
les agents seuls je crois que cette idée
là c'est une idée qui peut être un fil
conducteur à l'ensemble de notre action
jamais seul pour pouvoir mieux mesurer
il faut je le disais avoir plus d'homog
c'est le premier axe de priorité du plan
mieux mesurer les violences et les
menaces jamais seul aussi quand il
s'agit des administrations pour
mutualiser dans une logique de
prévention il s'agira et je le décriraai
de formation de déploiement de matériel
d'accompagnement humain jamais seul
aussi pour pouvoir mieux protéger c'est
le troisème axe de priorité que j'ai
voulu porter dès lors que des faits sont
avérés que ce soit des menaces ou ou des
agressions je je détaille peut-être très
rapidement avant de pouvoir ouvrir nos
échanges en détaillant le premier axe
sur la nécessité de mieux qualifier les
situations la réalité je le disais j'y
reviens pas c'est que toutes les
administrations ne mesurent pas
aujourd'hui et puis quand on mesure on a
pas de langage commun pour pouvoir
qualifier et quantifier les
agressiontions tout le monde n'a pas le
même les mêmes curseur si je puis dire
et donc on a un travail à mener
là-dessus et puis il faut être en
capacité aussi de mesurer
de façon continue pour pouvoir réagir et
anticiper se dire là il y a un point de
service public il y a un guichet où on a
un certain nombre de signaux Fabl qui
doivent nous conduire à mettre des
actions de prévention à renforcer la
sécurité et donc c'est la raison pour
laquelle j'ai annoncé qu'on allait
travailler en deux temps le premier
temps c'est de pouvoir mettre en place
un baromètre commun à l'ensemble des
administrations pour mesurer précisément
le nombre et la nature des actes de
violence subis par les agents publics et
pouvoir suivre leur évolution on va
s'appuyer pour faire sur un dispositif
qui est mis en place par les services
statistiques du ministère de l'Intérieur
qui est déployé auprès de 25000 agents
publics donc sur une base large qui nous
permettra d'avoir une gralularité fine
dans beaucoup et dans la majorité des
administrations et donc on pourra
publier une première édition de ce
baromètre au premier semestre 2024 pour
pouvoir avoir un suivi annuel et
régulier de ces actes de violence et
d'agression mais je le dis il faut aller
plus loin il faut aussi qu'on puisse
mettre en place des instruments dans
chaque administration pour pouvoir de
façon continue mesurer et remonter c'est
une des missions premièr que j'ai fixé à
notre comité de protection des agents
publics qui réunit donc l'ensemble des
administrations et l'ensemble des
opérateurs de travailler à la
construction de cet outil commun qui
sera complémentaire du baromètre annuel
deuxième axe je le disais c'est mieux
prévenir mettre en commun les outils de
prévention formation matérielle moyens
financiers moyens humains la formation
est essentielle elle peut pas être la
seule réponse évidemment mais on se rend
compte que pouvoir accompagner les
agents dans des action de prévention et
de formation ça fait beaucoup sur la
capacité à gérer l'agressivité à
organiser aussi parfois les services
pour pouvoir mieux prévenir les actes et
donc c'est la raison pour laquelle ces
derniers mois on a travaillé essay de
mutualiser l'ensemble des offres de
formation qui existaient y compris chez
les opérateurs certains étaient très
avancés sur ces questions-là travailler
avec des prestataires externes je pense
à la poste notamment qui a fait beaucoup
de travail pour ses postiers sur cette
question-là et donc j'ai demandé à la
direction interministale de la
transformation publique la dititp de
faire ce travail de mutualisation des
offres de formation ce qu'elle a fait
euh le euh dispositif de formation est
désormais prêt il sera à la fois
présentiel et distantiel et nous le
testons auprès d'agents public ces
dernières semaines nous
l'avons déployé à Marseille sur une
première formation près de 40 agents
publics d'administration diverses
certains agents notamment de de France
service mais aussi d'autres
administration et on envoie toute
l'utilité on va aussi le tester en sc
sainten d'ici les prochains jours et on
mettra à disposition la version
distantielle sur notre outil de de
déploiement des formations qui s'appelle
mentor pour la fonction publique pour
avoir le dispositif complet présentiel
et distantiel c'est un un module qui est
très complet je vous en cite quelques
chapitres connaître ses droits et ses
devoirs organiser la prévention
intervenir et soutenir les agents
signaler parler écouter prendre en
charge et prévenir la récidive un
certain nombre d'approches qui sont
extrêmement concrètes on travaille
évidemment avec le CNFPT pour la
territoriale et la NFH pour la fonction
publique hospitalière pour pouvoir
déployer ces outils là
formation matériel et dispositif de
protection on doit pouvoir accélérer
dans le déploiement de caméras de vidéo
protection de boutons d'alerte on voit
qu'il y a des boutons d'alerte qui sont
assez efficaces vous savez c'est ces
boutons où quand on appuie une fois
c'est d'abord les proches du service
deux fois on remonte à la hiérarchie
trois fois ça sonne directement à la
gendarmerie ou à la police on a
travaillé avec lugap donc la plateforme
d'achat de la fonction publique pour
avoir des marchés qui sont prêtes à
l'emploi et j'ai souhaité mettre des
fonds financiers pour pouvoir accélérer
le déploiement de ces dispositifs de
protection et de pas avoir de blocage à
court terme j'ai annoncé c'était cet été
dans un premier temps qu'on allait
débloquer 1 million d'euros j'ai
augmenté ses fonds à 3 millions d'euros
je l'ai annoncé cette semaine puisque
j'ai réuni l'ensemble des organisations
syndicales et l'ensemble des employeurs
publics pour travailler en commun sur
ces questions là et donc j'ai pu leur
indiquer qu'on débloqua ce fond de 3
million d'euros pour accélérer euh le le
déploiement de ces matériaux de
protection dans l'ensemble des des
administrations et puis j'ai évoqué sur
cette notion de mutualisation les moyens
humains qu'on doit pouvoir mettre à
disposition d'administration on voit
parfois de façon pas assez formalisée
mais ou systématiser plutôt le travail
très utile que peuvent faire nos
référents dans les commissariats et les
gendarmeries pour accompagner des
administrations c'est déjà le cas dans
des CHU par exemple pour pouvoir
travailler sur le bâtimentaire sur
l'organisation du service comment est-ce
qu'on fait pour avoir moins d'agents
seuls quand ils sont dans des situations
de devoir aller travailler par exemple
en extérieur de façon nomade la DG FIP
notamment à mener un travail intéressant
sur ces questionsl et donc nous sommes
en train de travailler à une convention
entre le Ministère de l'Intérieur et le
ministère de la transformation et de la
fonction publique pour pouvoir
systématiser la mise à disposition des
référents dans les poli des
commissariats et les gendarmeries pour
que ils puissent être à disposition des
administrations qu'ell souhaitent pour
les
accompagn trisème axe d'accompagnement
c'est de pouvoir mieux protéger les les
agents je le disais on a améliorer nos
dispositifs peut-être qu'on aura ces
échanges là ces dernières années sur la
la protection fonctionnelle notamment
vous l'évoquez monsieur le Président il
y avait encore pour moi des angles morts
dans ces dispositifs là je vais en
évoquer deux le premier c'est la
capacité des agents à aller au bout des
dépôts de plainte on voit bien que bien
souvent euh les les les agents subissent
le fait de devoir déposer plainte comme
une forme de double peine ils vivent une
agression sur leur lieu de travail et
ensuite on leur dit mais vous allez
déposer plainte demain sur votre temps
de repos c'est pas des soignants nous
font la la la réponse directement mais
ça devrait pas se marcher comme ça
parfois ils le vivent comme une
exposition supplémentaire en disant
est-ce que je vais pas me remettre une
deuxième fois en première ligne en
devant porter moi-même la plainte je
pense qu'il y a deux enjeux par rapport
à cette problématique là qui est
essentielle la première c'est déjà de
pouvoir déployer le bon accès au droit
et les bonnes pratiques il est déjà
possible par exemple pour un agent qui
déposerait plainte d'inscrire comme
adresse l'adresse de son administration
et pas l'adresse de son domicile ça
c'est des bonnes pratiques qui sont déjà
existantes et qu'on doit pouvoir
déployer c'est des choses qui sont aussi
concrètes que ça et puis il y avait
quand même un blocage qui était un
blocage au niveau de la loi c'est que
aujourd'hui euh une administration sauf
dans des cas qui sont aujourd'hui très
restreint n'a pas la possibilité de
porter plainte en lieu et place de
l'agent qui est agressé donc je souhaite
qu'on puisse corriger ce dispositif
législatif on a travaillé avec la
Chancellerie à un article de loi je le
soumettrai à la concertation dans le
cadre de la préparation et des
concertations sur un projet de loi pour
la fonction publique que je souhaite
porter et cet article là qui donne la
possibilité aux agents publics ou aux
délégataires de service public je crois
qu'on doit le porter de façon assez
élargie de porter plainte à la place des
agents ça sera à mon avis un signal
aussi essentiel qu'on enverra dans nos
administrations voilà pour ces extraits
de l'audition qui se tenait hier de
Stanislas Guerini pour en parler
j'accueill ici Max Brisson bonjour
bonjour vous êtes sénateur LR des
Pyrenées atlantiqu on retient dans cette
audition la difficulté à dénombrer le
nombre d'agressions de fonctionnaires on
comptait en 2021 35000 agressions de
soignants 12000 remontés par les agents
de la Caisse Nationale d'Assurance
familiale mais il manque des outils pour
faire le diagnostic de ces faits et
l'annonce du ministre c'est qu'il y aura
bientôt un baromètre commun aux
administrations c'est une bonne chose
qu'on est enfin des outils pour avoir
des des statistiques claires du nombre
d'agression oui mais ce gouvernement
procastine beaucoup on va de de
baromètres en observatoire on a eu la
même chose dans les écoles les collèges
et les lycées sur les atteintes à lacité
et l'ancien ministre s'était mis
quasiment à commenter les statistiques
comme on commente les statistiques du CH
age je pense qu'aujourd'hui les
fonctionnaires et les professeurs en
particulier qui sont en première ligne
attendent des décisions des mesures
l'observation est toujours intéressante
lorsqu'elle débouche sur de l'action et
le problème de ce gouvernement c'est
qu'il est dans la parole plus que dans
l'action dans l'observation plus que
dans l'action que dire aussi de ce fil
conducteur revendiqué par Stanislas
Guerini ne jamais laisser les agents
seuls c'est une bonne première étape
dans le monde de l'enseignement c'est
une grande nouveauté parce que que la
solitude le pas de vague ont marqué
l'institution finalement il fallait
recouvrir la la poussière par le tapis
plutôt qu'au contraire la la découvrir
donc oui qu'il y ait une volonté
maintenant une prise de conscience c'est
important maintenant la réalité à
l'école je parle essentiellement du
ministère qui est le plus grand
employeur de
fonctionnaires la protection des
fonctionnaires c'est le rétablissement
d'abord de l'autorité il y a sur les
actes de violence absolue lié au
terrorisme et là il s'agit d'autrre
chose mais les actes du quotidien ils
seront réprimés que si on redonne au
professeur l'autorité qu'on leura enlevé
tout simplement vous savez un professeur
autrefois il était le maître du jeu pour
l'orientation des élèves il était le
maître du jeu pour le passage dans
l'actat supérieur il était le maître jeu
dans la transmission des savoirs à force
d'avoir décidé que tout le monde avait
le même rôle la même place à l'école les
parents les élèves et que la parole du
l'élève valit la parole du professeur on
est dans cette situation est-ce que le
gouvernement au-delà des belles paroles
du ministratal est capable d'aller plus
loin je n'en suis pas persuadé justement
c'est la question que je vais vous poser
c'est la clé de voûe cette question de
l'autorité selon vous à droite on a
changé deux fois de ministre de l'INT de
ministre de l'éducation nationale depuis
2017 il y a eu Jean-Michel Blanquer
ensuite papend maintenant Gabriel hatal
est-ce que la nomination de ce ministre
depuis le mois de juin c'est une bonne
chose dans ce signal que vous voulez la
parole de Gabriel Atal est excellente le
ministre qui vient du Parti social liste
des rive à droite toute donc je ne vais
pas dire qu'il dit des bêtises puisqu'il
dit ce que nous disons depuis des années
donc nous avions raison et je suis très
heureux que le ministre de l'éducation
nationale donne raison à la droite
républicaine maintenant la parole c'est
une chose je vais prendre un exemple
très très simple comment on rétablit
l'autorité du professeur en conseil de
classe comment on rétablit l'autorité du
professeur en conseil de discipline
comment on donne au professeurs le droit
d'émettre des sanctions voilà quand
j'aurai des réponses à ces trois
questions très précises je vous dirai
que le ministre est passé de la parole à
l'acte une dernière question il nous
reste quelques secondes mais la
commission d'enquête va entendre Gabriel
hatal hein c'est l'une des prochaines
étapes pour cette commission d'enquête
qui réunit la commission des lois la
commission de la culture justement vous
attendez des annonces précises au-delà
de de de ce renforcement de l'autorité
c'est la clé de vous là encore oui
j'attendais réponse précise en disant
bien clairement qu'il y a des réponses
en termes de sécurité face à l'islamisme
et au terrorisme et qui sont d'un niveau
qui concerne le gouvernement tout entier
et le ministre de l'Intérieur en
premiereu et puis a des réponses aux
violences du quotidien qui décourageent
les professeurs et cela ne peut passer
que en redonnant des compétences des
pouvoirs à des professeurs qui les avait
il y a 10 ou 15 ans et bien merci merci
Max pour ce message très clair au micro
de public
c'estén c'est la fin de cette émission
merci à vous de l'avoir suivi n'hésitez
pas à lire tous les décrypt à retrouver
ses séances sur notre plateforme
numérique c'est publsenat.fr prochain
rendez-vous avec l'info dans quelques
minutes à 18h Thomas HUG et ses invités
qui reviendront notamment sur les suites
du projet de lo immigration au Parlement
très belle suite de programme sur public
[Musique]
Sat